que ahonda mi gente con mandamos
monterrey cómo andan cómo andan con sus
de aquí son felices están felices
ahorita a ver sonrían pues he perdido yo
estoy muy feliz y estoy muy contento por
estar aquí en monterrey me acabo de
venir apenas a vivir aquí tengo literal
un mes no soy tan feliz porque no me han
invitado ninguna carne nada
muy mal se crean ya va a sacar la
licencia para ver si me adoptan como
región invitan una carnita asada pero
estoy muy contento por estar aquí este
la verdad es que nunca me hubiera
imaginado estar en un té de c's la
verdad nunca me ha imaginado estar aquí
hablando con todos ustedes pero estoy
muy emocionado porque es algo que me
encanta me encanta compartir me encanta
hablar y todas compartir poquito de mi
historia y luego voy a pasar a ciertos
puntos unas ideas unas doctrinas unas
filosofías unos pensamientos que tengo y
quiero comenzar con un de repente
alguien de aquí le ha pasado a un de
repente en la vida bueno o malo puede
levantar tu mano si puede ser si quieres
no pasa nada
y había pasión de repente y cuando yo
estaba más o menos leía mis 23 siga
cumple 24 años yo iba saliendo a la
universidad me fui a el paso texas y ahí
estaba yo eso de chihuahua y me fui a la
universidad del paso ahí en la frontera
ción juárez el paso texas fue estudiar
la universidad y estoy de mercadotecnia
administración de empresas negocios
internacionales y yo estudié tres
carreras no porque me encantará estudiar
pero me mencionen mi casa fernando entre
más estudios tú tengas mejor te va la
vida cuantos aquí creen eso
no es del todo cierto verdad muchas de
las personas que no tienen estudios y
les va muy bien pero me enseñaron otra
cosa en mi casa y misión fernando las
relaciones es todo en la vida quien x y
cree eso depende a quien tú conozcas es
a dónde vas a llegar en otras palabras
los conectes las relaciones es todo en
la vida y eso vencieron mucho en mi casa
siempre lo hablaba era un lenguaje era
el pan de cada día en mi casa siempre
las relaciones y empecé a relacionarme
con muchas personas y cuando voy
saliendo de la universidad yo realmente
no tenía mucha experiencia estuve
trabajando ahí en gobierno gracias a una
relación me iba muy bien mientras estaba
en la escuela pero tuve que dejar ese
trabajo porque ya no se acomoda con el
horario de la escuela y me empecé a
endeudar porque no tenía un ingreso
entonces empecé a salir verdad seguía
saliendo con el mismo ritmo que salía
antes cuando tenía un ingreso y me
empecé a endeudar debía 300 mil pesos al
banco y un amigo de estos buenos amigos
me dice fernando vamos a las vegas'
pues yo de 21 años dije pues vámonos las
de ellas y están ahí en las vegas era un
evento de tres días y era una convención
de 17.000 personas ahora imagínate yo
estar medio atrás de 17.000 personas no
alcancé ni siquiera siento porque llegué
él y tal súper tarde ese evento y todo
lo que escuchaba hablar era acerca de
mentoría entrenamiento liderazgo y todo
el tiempo escuchaba verdad como gente
estaba emprendiendo a través del
internet y estaba generando ingresos a
través del internet yo estudié tres
carreras de negocios de cómo emprender
negocios tradicionales en mi casa me
enseñaron es vengo de una familia muy
tradicional de nuevos tradicionales y
veo como personas están ganando miles de
dólares a través del internet ni
siquiera estaban en la escuela y ganaban
y ganaban y un estilo de vida de viajar
de todo desde la computadora desde el
celular
yo dije yo quiero eso yo quiero eso
quiero eso y ahí estoy por tres días de
viernes a domingo ahí estoy tres días
escuchando de estos testimonios de estas
personas de cómo están generando a
través del internet y yo recuerdo que al
final verdad una persona la final del
evento empieza a compartir todo su
testimonio toda la parte de que él
aprendió y él y él compartió esto y
siempre me quedó súper súper claro
verdad porque él dijo todo lo que soy
todo lo que tengo es gracias a un mentor
a una persona que tiene el ejemplo
verdad que puso el ejemplo yo lo único
que hice es que pregunté qué fue
exactamente lo que hizo le copié y hoy
por hoy es lo que tengo y esta persona
estaba generando en ese momento un
millón 250 mil dólares al mes
por mi mente lo único que pasaba era yo
quiere ganar dos mil dólares al mes yo
dije quiero salir de la escuela
conseguir un buen trabajo que me pague
40 mil 45 mil pesos mensuales y ya se
armó can con eso hasta me caso me siento
seguro nada certero dos mil dólares al
mes y escucho gente ganando esas
cantidades de dinero a través del
internet dije que estoy yo quiero y
salgo de allí bien impactado porque yo
nunca había escuchado la palabra mentora
hasta ese día y todo lo que hice es que
busque a esa persona por internet y lo
comencé a seguir y esa persona se
convirtió en un primer mentor y este
mentor me empezó a enseñar ciertas cosas
y te quiero compartir porque ahí viene
el de repente y este mentor me decía
fernando tienes que dedicarle todos los
días a tu mente aprendizaje este mentor
me decía que se dedicaba a una hora de
aprendizaje todos los días a mi mente mi
mente por consecuencia iba a cambiar
este mentor me decía acción y le
dedicaba a mi mente a leer libros
escuchar audiolibros a estudiar
biografías de personas muy exitosas por
consecuencia todos los días una hora
iban a ser 365 horas de aprendizaje al
año por consecuencia a mi mente iba a
ser transformada cambiada
y todo lo que yo hacía me decía es que
por tanto que tú lees te educas y estás
dedicándole ese conocimiento a tu mente
viene a lo que se le llama renovación el
renovar tu mente el reinventarte ahora
me encanta esta definición me encanta
este tema de aquí de te de ex de
reinvención por que reinventarte
significa no cambiar tu pero si cambiar
tu forma de ser si cambiar tu manera de
pensar si cambiar llegará un cambio y
sabes que el cambio incomodan y yo
cuando estaba en ese momento ahora
escuchando a este mentor me decía muchas
cosas que yo tenía que hacer y realmente
me incomodaba pero eran cambios que yo
tenía que hacer imaginé tener una
persona que para mí en ese momento ahora
nunca había escuchado de alguien que
ganaba un millón de dólares al mes y
empecé a hacer exactamente lo que esta
persona me dijo empecé a leer libros
escucharon de un libro y este mentor me
decía que entre más yo hiciera eso por
consecuencia iba a hacer más y que
cuando tú eres más por consecuencia
sabes más y cuando sabes más vas a hacer
más así que cuando haces más vas a ganar
más en otras palabras si tú quieres
ganar más vas a tener que hacer más y
para tú hacer más vas a tener que ser
más
con todo si quieren saber más en otras
palabras si quieres saber más vas a
tener que tener un mentor alguien que te
enseñe que te diga cómo hacerlo yo
empecé empecé empecé empecé empecé y me
dice este mentor ponte una meta o en 18
meses cuánto quieres ganar y yo veía que
el promedio de la gente lo que ganaba
era 20 mil dólares al mes yo quiere
ganar dos mil dólares agregue un cero
más por ahí escuché no de todos no si
vas a soñar sueña en grande y le agregué
un cero más y dije bueno vamos por 18
meses y lo logré en 11 meses en 11 meses
estamos en veintiún mil dólares al mes y
no te lo digo por el dinero sino en la
persona que me estaba convirtiendo todo
por estar siguiendo a esta persona y yo
estaba ahí en el paso texas de la nunca
había viajado nunca nunca he viajado
viajaba ahí cerca de chihuahua y algunas
ciudades de por ahí porque yo puse
interés en primero yo crecer empezar a
trabajar verdad a dedicarle mis mejores
tiempos al trabajo a invertir en mí
mismo y empiezo a generar esas
cantidades de dinero y empiezo a viajar
y empezar a hacer por todo el mundo y en
eso vienen mis amigos y qué onda 20
invitamos salir y esperar tengo es que
estoy cambiando espera te ves que todo
cosas que hacer y un momento donde me
quedé sin amigos porque todo lo que
hacía era realmente puedes dedicarle a
mí ya mi sueño tenía una meta y llega un
momento donde estoy trabajando y me doy
cuenta que hay muchas muchas cosas ahí
afuera y que van variantes en niveles
cuantos de aquí creen que hay niveles
dile a tu vecino y dile hay niveles que
delay nivel si no tienes de cine o de
miami en niveles hay niveles cuantos
aquí creen que hay niveles si vas a
viajar hasta a dónde vas a dejar si o no
hay niveles
hasta en la aerolínea que vas a viajar
si no hay niveles cuando vas al banco y
cómo te tratan si o no hay niveles hasta
en la fila en la que estás a formada en
el aeropuerto si o no hay niveles no hay
niveles yo quería subir de nivel y hay
un cuate que dice así francés franck y
para nuevos niveles nuevos demonios
y me da miedo ese concepto verdad como
lo dice el apóstol pablo en la biblia en
el nuevo testamento dice hay una buena
batalla y esa batalla dice no peleamos
ni contra carne ni contra sangre no
peleamos contra gente no peleamos contra
el envidioso contra el sela contra el
celoso peleamos contra mentalidades
contra forjamiento contra caracteres
contra creencias contra eso es que tú
peleas todo el tiempo y lo llamo la
buena batalla ahora te quiero hace esta
pregunta a todas aquellas personas que
ya tienen su negocio o quieren emprender
o de todos modos el éxito que estés
buscando llamar el éxito saludable
amoroso espiritual si tú sales ahorita
al mundo a la vida querer emprender a
querer cambiar a que rinden reinventar
te crees que sea fácil o difícil
fácil o difícil crees que sea crees que
vayas a batallar crees que sea buena la
batalla ahí afuera cuando quieres
cambiar quieres transformar el mundo
quiere transformar tu mundo yo creo que
va a ser buena la batalla estamos de
acuerdo ahora cuando tú vas a pelear que
necesitas armas y vamos a ver si es
cierto todo esto que te digo que hay
niveles y si realmente verdad está
difícil la batalla que es lo que hay más
allá fuera gente negativa o gente
positiva
negativa
qué es lo que hay más allá afuera gente
rica gente pobre
tú crees que saliendo allá afuera vaya a
estar buena la batalla claro que sí
imagínate todas esas mentalidades
imagínate todas esas maneras de pensar
te lo dice una persona que empezó a
trabajar con muchísimas personas en
diferentes partes del mundo y siempre me
topaba con estas maneras de pensar y
decir wow necesita ver un despertar y
donde creamos un movimiento que se llama
despertando líderes porque yo me daba
cuenta que nos necesitamos más gente
sino más líderes y liderazgo tú sabes
que es todo es lo que hace que una
persona grita lo escuchaste de otras
personas aquí el liderazgo lo que hace
que una persona siempre de lo
extraordinario por consecuencia haga lo
extraordinario y siempre va a saber las
masas las multitudes y una entorno decía
fernando se hace es totalmente lo
opuesto te aseguro que no le va a cerrar
y yo estaba ahí aprendiendo de estas
personas de estos mentores y me daba
cuenta que cada vez que tú querías
emprender o hace algo diferente te topas
con estas maneras de pensar que era
diferente era diferente era difícil era
difícil y es este este mismo ejemplo que
te digo si yo voy ahorita a una
biblioteca a una librería que crees que
hay más de libros libros positivos
libros negativos
positivos can
no es como que yo haya la librería de la
biblioteca y diga señorita me da el
libro de cómo ser pobre en tres días
señora le encargó el libro de cómo
perder mi familia en siete pasos
le encargó el libro de cómo divorciarme
y si me entiendes no hay esos libros que
hagan si entiendes por qué porque todo
eso abunda todo eso ya abundó y todo eso
ya existe hoy si yo puedo salir del
círculo entonces imagínate estar en una
burbuja todo el tiempo en un cuadro
donde te bien todo el tiempo bueno hagas
esto nada lo otro es a ti veces puede
creencia ese tipo de mentalidad
todo el tiempo lo veía todo lo que acá
lo que te acabo de explicar todo eso ya
abunda ya fuera entonces decía el
apóstol para lobo y la batalla o está
aquí donde necesitan las armas aquí que
necesitas todos esos libros esa mentoría
esa renovación de la mente esa
reinvención reinventarte todo el tiempo
pero qué crees la mayoría de la gente no
nos gustan los cambios si tú estuvieras
viendo la tele horita y llegó y le
cambio te gustaría ver lo que no nos
gustan los cambios el cambio incómoda
pero qué crees va a ser el primer
principio al éxito el cambio si una
persona está cómoda no califica para el
cambio
necesitas incomodarte todo el tiempo y
yo ahí empecé a incomodar me empecé a
trabajar con diferentes personas
empezamos
y viajar y ayudar a más personas y te lo
dice una persona te digo que realmente
nunca había ganado en mi casa todo mundo
se burlan de mí
porque estoy explicando el internet que
no sé qué y era difícil todos los
comentarios hay o escucharlos en mi casa
pero yo tenía un mentor yo tenía estas
personas that como decían ahorita que me
estaban hablando todo el tiempo y sigue
creyendo síguele dando ahí y empezamos a
realmente crear una organización cada
vez más grande en todo el mundo verdad
despertando líderes despertando líderes
y ese era el plan despertar la mente de
la gente y yo creo esto soy un fiel
creyente que la mayoría de la gente tú y
yo somos lo que somos basado en lo que
hemos pensado hasta el día de hoy tú y
yo somos desde que naciste dijo wood a
lo que piensas es lo que eres dijo
jesucristo tal es tu pensamiento en tu
alma en tu mente en tu subconsciente tal
eso eres tú todo lo que tú y yo somos es
basado en pensamientos y esos
pensamientos viene siempre muchas veces
las personas con las que nos juntamos
dime con quién te juntas y te diré
quién eres
quién eres lo mismo es de tus amigos
eso eres que mira de estos amigos eso
eres en eso te estás convirtiendo
y cuando yo empiezo a escuchar estas
frases que ya las hemos escuchado pero
yo en ese momento no sabía realmente
edad porque no mi mente no estaba
despierta hasta que no empecé a
despertar despertar gracias al cambio de
mi mente verdad gracias a ese tipo de
pensamientos que empezaban a sembrar ahí
en mí gracias a estos mentores a estos
libros mi mente constantemente escúchame
se empezó a ir reinventar
yo no cambié mi identidad era la misma
un hombre un líder un hijo de dios
empresario emprendedor licenciado
mercadotecnia administración de empresas
pero sabía que tenía que cambiar mi
manera de pensar sabía que tenía que
cambiar ciertas cosas sabía que tenía
que incomodar me tenía que yo sea una
persona nueva y empezamos verdad cada
vez tengo nueve años emprendiendo por
internet llegó un momento donde yo
quería hablar verdad lo que yo quería
hablar acerca de mi gente en ese negocio
donde yo comencé hace nueve años y no me
dejaban no me dejaban imagínate estar yo
17 mil personas atrás hace 9 años en un
evento donde yo nunca me había imaginado
a hablar en frente miles de personas
porque no ganara 20 mil dólares al mes
hasta que gane más y más y más y no
tenido por presunción tenido por
testimonio genuino que llegó un momento
hace dos años donde dije una madre hoy
voy a tener que abrir mi empresa y
abrimos nuestra empresa y se llama brand
ibex es una empresa en el word marketing
y son más de 70 mil usuarios en todo el
mundo tenemos oficinas en youtube
corporativas oficinas en texas tenemos
oficinas en guadalajara de marketing
tenemos oficinas en la india de
tecnología estamos poder oficinas en
dubai estamos por abrir oficinas aquí en
san pedro y te lo dice una persona que
realmente hoy yo no me imaginaba estando
en ese evento hace nueve años que yo iba
a ser como aquel bebé que estaba
hablando ahí y que estaba ganando lo que
estaba ganando
no imaginaba pero sí me imaginé algo que
si ese güey pudo yo también podía hablar
sin muchos que hagan esa la dona quien
te de c's
yo también podría hablar si esa persona
estaba engañando lo que estaba ganando
dije yo puedo yo no me imaginaba en ese
evento yo crear mi propia empresa mi
propia empresa como la esa persona que
estaba ahí parado
que hicimos creamos otra llamada y ex
global alex brandon ex hablando ente de
c's
y terminando
hace un año literal hace un año literal
este movimiento despertando líderes lo
enfocamos con tres cosas y terminan
estos tres minutos me di cuenta que el
despertar de cada líder de cada persona
eran tres anclajes casi todo te lo
hablaron ahorita las personas que
estaban aquí
y dio compartirte esto y con esto
termino número 1 si tú quieres irte a un
siguiente nivel económico y espiritual
saludable lo que sea que estés buscando
un siguiente nivel siempre va a estar en
tu mente tres anclajes que te van a
detener siempre número uno creencias
limitantes eres lo que eres basado en
todo lo que has creído hasta el día de
hoy todas tus creencias agua no porque
seas de una familia millonaria o y que
te vaya muy bien una familia bien de
principio no significa nada cuando tú te
sales de esa burbuja te das cuenta que a
lo mejor ciertas creencias están
repitiendo patrones de tu papá no porque
vengan de una familia donde no había
dinero no significa que tus creencias
tus principios estén bien no porque tu
papá no haga nada más no significa que
tú pudieras ganar más no porque alguien
en tu familia tenga esa enfermedad
significa que un doctor venga y te pueda
decir agua y tuvieron diabetes tú
también vas a tener diabetes no
significa nada que tus creencias
limitantes siempre te van a detener
cuando quieras ir a un siguiente nivel
llámale el éxito que estás buscando no
importan número dos miedos miedos me
encanta esta parte en este libro de la
biblia porque dicen no sé tengo un
espíritu de miedo
y la ciencia dice que el miedo es una
emoción y una emoción y motion es una
energía en movimiento ahora imagínate
esta energía en movimiento es un cercano
y la biblia está diciendo que el miedo
es un espíritu ahora imagínate la
mayoría de la gente todo el tiempo todos
los días tenemos miedo hay un versículo
para cada día del año más de 365
versículos en la biblia que dicen no
tengan miedo y no temas todo el tiempo
será importante que nos diga eso claro
que sí es una de las cosas de los
anclajes que tu mente siempre va a tener
y te va a limitar para poderte ir a un
siguiente nivel aún poderte despertar
despertar tu consciencia despertar tu
liderazgo un siguiente nivel el miedo
todo miedo que se cura con acción hay
gente que me dice oye voy porque no te
tiras del paracaídas buenos que tengan
hijos simplemente yo sé que esas madres
a lo mejor no siempre funciona me quiero
morir todavía
pero hoy no pasa nada no tengo miedo te
lo juro pero qué tal si no se abre es
verdadera
muy frontal paracaídas porque no también
estás en los negocios
porque si no te dan miedo a invertir
porque no te dan miedo a arriesgar
porque no te dan viendo otras cosas los
miedos todos se van a curar con acción
punto final y número 3 el más importante
los apegos creencias limitantes miedos y
los apegos lo dice la palabra el
apegarse a algo a alguien todo apego mi
gente de emshi un te rey todo apego
viene de una emoción podrá ser la
persona más inteligente más culta más
sabia más millonaria del mundo de mayor
experiencia no importa quién seas
si no tienes inteligencia emocional si
de todos modos sigues apegado a una
persona a una relación como lo dijeron
ahorita tan sencillo como la cura al
miedo va a ser la acción la cura a todo
emoción y cerrar un ciclo va a ser con
el perdón
va a ser con el perdón
tres anclajes los dominas te lo juro que
siempre te irás a un siguiente nivel
quieres despertar habían dos niños
patinando en hielo
y de repente uno se cae se quiebra el
hielo está por debajo del agua está
haciendo mucho frío el otro niño
asustado veía que no había nadie le
empieza a pegar al hielo quiebra el
hielo rescata al niño y en eso llegan
alcanzan a llegar ve a los bomberos
llegan los policías y dicen que pasión
como es que este niño con tan pequeña
mano pudo quebrar ese hielo y rescatar a
su amigo y viene a lo lejos un anciano
verdad diciendo yo sí sé qué pasó cómo
fue por qué pasa es que no había nadie
que le dijera que no podía hacerlo
no había nadie que le pudiera decir allí
en ese momento no creo que puedas no
hacer nada escúchame me liberé de
monterrey
siempre siempre que quieras hacer algo
lo que sea que tengas que hacer te la
tienes que creer cuidado con quién te
juntás cuidado a quien estás escuchando
pero siempre para llegar a un siguiente
nivel vas a tener que despertar vas a
tener que reinventar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]